that baby Fool's Day its youtubers happy
April Fool's Day and I just want to make
this quick video to let you guys know if
you haven't figured it out already
YouTube switched and flipped their
videos upside down
people have done videos on how to unlock
them I'm just going to show you that
whenever you click a video from the home
screen then it looks a little something
like this now this is an HD video so
it'll have the HD button upside down
okay all of the text is upside down so
this upside down and upside down my name
is upside down it still flips vertically
but it's upside down all the text is
upside down says also watching now
upside down and yeah so even if I try to
type that in that's upside down also
yeah so if I want to flip this all
upside right-side up I should say even
the subscribe button is upside down but
I've already subscribed to text occasion
check those channel you just go back up
here to the URL bar and see this last
part where it says and flip equals one
delete it hit enter and everything is
right side up again see everything's
alright setup looks just fine so yeah
I'm gonna finish watching the rest of
this video but I just thought I'd let
you guys know that's how you flip them
right side up and that's basically it
happy April Fool's Day hope you played a
good prank today and I'm still waiting
to hear about the Conficker worm is it a
virus is it an April Fool's hoax peace